with that what I'd like to do is
introduce today's speakers there are two
faculty members who are joining with
today very honored and our esteemed
guests the first is professor Stephen
Boyd
professor Boyd is a Samsung professor in
engineering and the professor of
Electrical Engineering at Stanford
University his current research focuses
on convex optimization applications in
control signal processing and circuit
design professor Board received his AV
degree in mathematics summa laude
from Stanton from Harvard University in
1980 and has a PhD and electrical
engineering computer science from UC
Berkeley and you can see that in 1985 in
1985 you joined the faculty of
Stanford's electrical engineering
department professor Boyd is the author
of many research articles and three
books linear controller design limited
performance linear matrix inequality
Zanda system and control theory and
convex optimization professor Boyd has
received many awards and honors for his
research and control systems engineering
and optimization including the Office of
Naval Research Young Investigator award
the presidential Young Investigator
award the IBM faculty development award
the ACC Donald P Eklund award and is a
fellow of the I Triple E we're also
joined today by Professor Simon Wong
professor Wang is the vice chair of
electrical engineering and a professor
there he received his Bachelor degree in
electrical engineering mechanical
engineering from the University of
Minnesota and as MS and PhD degrees in
California Berkeley we're glad that both
these faculties of UC roots of John
Stanford University his industrial
experience includes semiconductor memory
design at national semiconductor and
semiconductor technology development of
fuel at Packard Labs he was assistant
professor at Cornell University from 88
85 to 88 and since 88 has been on the
faculty of Stanford University where he
is now professor and vice chair of
electrical engineering
his current research concentrates on
understanding and overcoming the factors
that limit performance and devices
interconnects on ship components and
packages he's also a fellow the
and it's served on advisory boards of al
Pharaohs communications and profound
semiconductor now I'd like to preparing
the floor over to Professor Wang who
will walk us through e e future as we
see it here today good morning everybody
can you hear me welcome to this
presentations where we would like to
tell you where we see the future
opportunities of electrical engineering
would be so if you look go back the
history and look at what we have
accomplished these are many companies
that have been started by Stanford
faculties or alum and you can see that
we indeed has been very successful in
generating new applications based on
electrical engineering so what we'll
have what have we done
how things are in fundamentals we
understand physics very well we
understand how we deal with very complex
math and combining the two we very
skillful in developing models that
describe the physics to the point that
it will allow us to perform very
detailed analysis of very complex
systems and also innovate designed for
very useful systems so that's when we
solve real problems and we find new
applications for our technologies and
math okay if you look at some of the
major innovation that has occurred over
the last few decades and so always
occurs at the intersection of sines and
now examples if you look at integrated
circuit we start of understanding
electron in semiconductors but that's
not enough that's all we did that we
anniver there's a whole bunch of
individual transistors but being able to
develop the map that is why very complex
systems particular linear systems being
able to solve these matrix of equation
using sparse matrix techniques
simulation and Nehring allow us to
design very complex integrated circuits
of course extending that too
the descriptor men domain allow us to
design micro process of the power to
control computing industry you can also
book across for examples in
communications areas that's been around
for many many years but the reason boom
is basically taking knowledge and
electromagnetic wave propagation and
combining that with the ability to
process digital signal very effectively
and understanding statistically how how
these signal will behave so then we come
up with digital wireless technologies
similarly in the optical communications
there's the integrations of
understanding how photons behave
understanding how we can manipulate the
photons understand the statistics of how
they will behave in Milazzo systems and
how do we extract it use of information
out that so so usually these creating a
new application area new company or new
industry is usually occurs right at the
intersections so as we look into the
future what are the new entire
inspection one of these new big circles
that might occur I think that's where we
are trying to address today ok
one thing that power all these
innovation of course in was laws which
allow us to have many more transistors
onto a chip it's been a very amazing how
Moore's law has continually able to
progress in spite of all the technology
challenge where cross over a hundred
nanometers over decades ago we're now
about a crossovers ten nanometers
approaching an antenna because there's
been a lot of protection that this is
all our above the limit I don't believe
that is the case I can remember that
when I was a grad student crossing under
1 micron was very very typical and we
did indeed cross over that and then when
I became a faculty stand was going under
hundred nanometer was almost impossible
and we did that and so I think this this
type of progress will continue of course
it will require more innovation in signs
and and technologies and there's no
doubt that the cost of doing this will
become increasingly
hires however I think there's other
posts that we're also looking at that
will also enhance scaling if you look at
scaling it's going really not just about
putting more transistors on a chip it is
giving the consumers a functions at a
lower cost so if you have other ways
that can achieve that that could also be
possible so one thing that might happen
so is already happening is
three-dimensional integrated circuits at
the industry in the next slides over
here can you go and buy a chip today's a
lot of them for example your flash cards
already have multiple chip stack one on
top of each other so this allow us to
increase the the right density without
any significant improvement in
technology all I need is more
sophisticated packaging or bonding
technologies waiver stacking stacking
multiple wafers is already close to
productions in fact some foundry has
already announced that they will be
providing this type of service towards
the end of this years of course the
ultimate goal here is to allow us a
monolithic simply stack transistor right
on Carmelo's this is an area where we
conducting Advanced Research in so the
next slide illustrate to you what one
can do is indeed one can fabricate
transistor less than 400 degree C so
this far
IRA's rage Amenia MOSFET that's been
fabricated at temperature less than 400
degree C and of course with such a low
temperature it means that we can
fabricate a transistor right on top of
metals which allow us to stack
transistor right on top of each others
right on top of all the metallization
layers align them perfectly and fully
can you connect all these really
multiple layers of transistors and you
can see that one advantage of
transmission medium is that the females
to hold actually have better mobility
than silicon so not only that we're
allowing three dimensional integration
circuits what happened we are actually
providing higher performance device so I
think it's these type of innovations
that will allow us to continue to
progress according to Moore's law but in
a different way that we have done in the
past there's another whole area that we
haven't even explored which is to put
photons on top of chips here's again
because of the advancements of
having technology we're now looking at
quantum photonics you can see that we
can build quantum dots or these are
quantum dots allow us to immediately
like more effectively within do quantum
information processing allow us to send
signal from one positivity to the other
boxes with optical means and so all
these things will also allow us to
integrate not just electron on chip but
also photons and again that allow us to
progress in accordance more but again in
the different dimensions okay so what
are the new things that are happening
other than just electrons photons and
Gemelli that we've been playing with
it's a whole new area coming up with
biology in which we're dealing mostly
with neurons and this is another new
form of particles that through the
proper integration with math we think
there will be a lot of interesting
applications so next slide illustrate
one of those one of those applications
here is a you can see this is a man's
face a sensor electrolyte array that's
faculty using silicon MEMS technologies
and these erases then it has all the
electronic sensing mechanic on top of
that if they find that included the
brain in this case the experiments
conducted with monkey they were in time
into the monkey brains and though here's
is to watch the brain these signals and
not just watch the signal but process it
and most importantly we take what the
monkey will do so this is much more
advanced than just sensing but it's also
there's involved estimation predictions
and with that we will be able to predict
if a monkey once it's an motor sensor
was right or two at the left and with
all those information we will now be
able to help our patient who might have
emotions problems other areas that we
are also making Francis in the imaging
area medical imaging areas nmo is of
course one of the two does becoming more
and more popular and within footmen in
the algorithm that process the image
this is again an advancement in math
we're now being able to see much more
details in Bihar divisions and also the
the vessels in the in the like so these
are these are tremendous improvement in
the imaging is Peary just by advancement
in the math of course advancement in
physics will also help in medical
imaging the next slide illustrate one
such improvement at this point and I'm
out though is very powerful it's usually
not performed on children for a couple
reasons one is it's very hard to convene
the children's is emotionless throughout
the entire process and if they move
around the initial cap door and so a lot
of time the student has go for instance
yes and see if they want to go through
this kind of process which is kind of
expensive and lengthy so by improving
the system capability evolving
increasing the magnetic field and also
the sentence circuitry we're now able to
conduct as image as significant for the
times in terms of minutes rather than
half an hour so and these imaging allow
us to perform and now on children which
in many cases are beneficials
okay what are the area that we think
that we new horizon these are in the
energy and environment areas of course
these are areas that everybody's now
have a lot of renewing interest and a
couple areas that we're focusing on one
is the energy areas Stanford is of
course well known for our research
preferably shirts in solar cells in fact
one of our former colleague is the
founders of Sun power now they're with
silicon solar cells already in
large-scale productions we're looking at
different alternative material so the
mixed by illustrate to you one of those
material we're looking at which is
organic solar cell materials this is
done by Professor Peter humans and here
we want to build the solar cell using
the theory that can be spray on very low
cause on flexible substrate so that you
can roll up the solar cell as that
multiple layers or be solar cells to
increase this efficiency so again these
are breakthrough technology that will
follow any da one they will find
applications in the environment area our
our focus at many on Imaging's looking
from the outside rope back down to earth
and and look at these how the
environment may impact our conditions
living conditions and and these are just
some examples of those although none
these are not involved in the focus yet
but the same technology will allow us to
look at the environment issues so these
are imaging of volcanoes Croatian
velocity of course this allow us to
detect global warming much more
effectively and it's also maybe even
when they allow us to predict earthquake
in California so these are again based
on technology that are largely available
already but combining with more
advancement in the masks which allow us
to achieve all these imaging techniques
ok so at this point we have no doubt
that the future is very exciting with
the addition of nano and bio neurons in
these physics areas we're now exploring
new quantum effects and we're looking at
new devising technologies in the
environment energy and environmental
initiatives we are expanding our
applications of ice testing technologies
now without any doubt we're dealing with
increasing complexity so we need more
more development in the math area so
professor stephen boy will will say a
few more words about the developments in
the MAF areas if you look at all these
exciting features one recessive of
course is just a lot of things that one
need to learn in order to capture these
opportunities so this is why we're here
today to tell you what we're doing to
help you to learn these new material
with reasonable amount of pain not not
substantial amount of pain ok ok we
understand that we all do they deliver a
lot of courses for spce but all of these
causes tend to be very intensive because
they're designed for our own students in
which we expect them to practice in such
areas and while about time we don't
really want to go into depth a lot of us
just want to understand the physics what
are the basics so that in one day we
need to use that we can go into the
theft furnace
so the starting the summers we're gonna
start offering these a pretty varied
aversion of these courses they will be
about two units and they will cut all
the essential materials and they will
have me but not now in this summer these
four courses that offers don't have
projects but they will instead of having
tens week of instruction they would have
paid with some instruction so it will
cover 80% of the material and it will
give you a good base to understand the
material and if you want to broaden your
knowledge in these areas with how a lot
of painters is probably a good way to do
it these causes cannot be counted to was
the master death or breath so in case
you're working on
a degree this is perhaps a limitation
but it can be countered and other units
if you're working on a certificate
program they will become a tuition
certificate programs if we see something
sufficient interest over the summer then
over the next year we'll start offering
even more more abbreviated version of
just the Regulus SPC P courses for
examples a lot of the courses involve a
project design we understand that you're
already working in industry you have a
lot of experience with project design
this perhaps perhaps no need to ask you
to conduct another project
so those causes will again be it's a
Roberto we could lighten for example by
not asking you to perform the final
projects but that I could stop at this
point and see if there any questions
from the audience first along thank you
very much for that introduction to both
the opportunities in electrical
engineering and also some of the courses
that are offered I actually have one
question for you
in so where if our students are
professional and an electrical
engineering and I'm looking to retool
does the e Department have useful
resources on the website or what what
should I do
okay we have on our website a list of
all the courses we offers and and you
can click on that and also
the courses that also also offer an espy
CD you can go for SPC be website to
identify those courses great thank you
also if you find a course that over on
campus but not on SP CD you can always
request to come to campus of the Tendo
courses too terrific that's that's great
advice with regard to these four courses
there are each two units which as you
mentioned reduces the load what what
kind of indication would you need from
industry students who may be interested
in in terms of maybe doing this for a
broader series of courses what are you
looking for um we are now experimenting
with this approach so we're looking for
suggestions from the industry if you
look at a course and you like to see
some of the contents you know take an
hour or remove to for the abbreviated
course we're certainly open to those
suggestions
now if you want to find out more about
these courses what's going to be covered
this summer you can actually click on
our website there's a link for summer
courses to be offered two summers and
you can click on it the the syllabus for
all these courses are posted so you
magic tell how much of it is going to be
talk we also describe what an appeal we
have taken now so you can also tell
pacano until you've been missing
those are great resources professional
long I want to thank you very much and
if you have questions as we go through
the program we'll take those at the end
and with that I want to turn it to a
professor Stephen Boyd who will actually
drill down on two of the four courses
that we have talked about here today or
have highlighted the first one is EE 263
professor Boyd
thanks Paul also Thank You Simon for
giving a very good overview and setting
the stage for the things I'm going to
talk about I'm gonna actually talk about
in much more detail two specific course
and set EE 263 and EE 364 a the slides I
have here are culled from the course
material I won't cover all of them but
I'll just give you just a
explore what these courses are about and
how it fits into the big picture and why
you might want to know about this this
material also I'll say something about
how it fits in with the general trends
that Simon was was describing some I
should mention that both of these
courses all of the material for the
entire course all material is available
on the website just go to google and
type in any of these things and you'll
find them immediately um that will give
you a really good idea to find out if
you want to know what's in these courses
and you'll find out that in fact there's
a lot in these courses and that's sort
of the idea behind the the S versions
means the abbreviated summer versions is
to is to make these go down to a
something which is to an essential idea
so let me talk about 263 first this is
the course of linear dynamical systems
and the basic topics covered is this
linear algebra and applications I should
say in the in the broad scheme of things
this is one of the very core courses
that Simon referred to as the as one of
the mathematical hands and I should say
how that fits in them where we consider
ourselves consumers of or beneficiaries
of Moore's law so while people like
Simon and his colleagues work out the
technology to keep this this relentless
scaling going on we're the ones to
figure out cool things to do with all
this power so for us it's a lot of fun
because otherwise a lot of this stuff
would be just math but what's cool about
it is it's it is math the really cool
part is it's also in your iPod so I mean
and your and your your cell phone so
anyway all right I want to talk a little
bit about that um 2:53 is gone is going
to is the main topic is basically
applied to linear algebra and and part
of that we talk about linear dynamical
systems and we do a little bit of
quadratic control and estimation now one
question is you know why would you want
to study linear systems well my opinion
is that these are interesting because
they come up in tons of applications
areas and by the way well
these days so the most obvious ones are
automatic control systems you know for
vehicles but for many many things many
products have embedded control systems
in them signal processing has now moved
towards something where basically all
modern signal processing uses linear
dynamical systems almost all it's making
a huge impact in communication so that
if you want to do modern you know
wireless communications you have to know
this material kind of period but it's
also got a lot of it's got a lot of
other applications it's in areas like
economics and finance which is kind of
cool to learn one area of applied math
it has applications and lots of areas so
I already mentioned this that in fact
it's it's the basis for things like
spice and circuit simulation at the end
of the FFN and a device stimulation at
the end of the day a lot of these things
come down to solving large sets of
linear equations maybe many times but
that's the idea
um also comes up in mechanical and civil
engineering aeronautics navigation and
guidance and this is just a first just a
short list I mean other areas would be
statistics and operations research and
there is like that so there's a lot of
applications now that depends on the
type of material now the usefulness of
this of course depends on available of
computing power so which is what which
is now very very large at this moment
and increasing exponentially your many
people using that word incorrectly so
but here it's absolutely correct it's
just Moore's law so these are things you
know if anyway if this if there's any so
that we can consume this is one things
you can do with these absolutely
requires large computing power now you
can use this computing power for
analysis and design that's clearly been
done but actually more and more accused
in implementation and embedded in real
time system so more and more you find
actually the control laws that run in
things are quite sophisticated involve
more than some very simple calculations
that can actually be running full linear
dynamical systems some
and they have this fixing historically
digital signal processing you know it
started up the traces to let's say MIT
in the 60s or something like that maybe
a bit earlier depends where you want to
you know where you want to do the cutoff
but at first that was a very advanced
topic you know taken by PhD students and
it was very expensive technology the
only you know only the military would
use it for very high-end products and
things like that
now DSP as you know and again this is
just directly related to Moore's law as
a consequence it's now you bit is
everywhere it is an undergrad it's an
undergraduate class it's in all
electronics and so on so and I think the
same thing is going to happen the linear
dynamical systems that's really sort of
happening now that is transitioning from
in the 60s a pensive carrack advanced
topic that you would use to guide
missiles so now something that's
basically in all the products all in all
the electronics around you so that's
sort of that's the way I see this this
material the trend here and why it's
interesting okay a little bit on the
origin in history of linear dynamical
systems well first of all it the math
can be traced some of it can be traced
the 19th century and it can be sauna but
something like this is classical
circuits and systems that's the material
from the 20s that's transfer functions
and poles and zeros and things like that
kind of meets linear algebra that's what
this course is really now the first
giant engineering application was
aerospace in the 60s which is really
enabled but by these methods so I mean
you don't do you don't do space stuff
without this period so but somewhere in
the 80s this transitions from a
specialized topic to to one that's
widely used and one that you know a lot
of you have to know if you do if you do
a lot of areas and not just an
electrical engineering but other areas
and this is something like digital
signal processing and information theory
which also transit transition from a
very mathematical very abstract you're
either one that's widely used all are
all around and all sorts of applications
so I'm going to very quickly look
and at an example just to give you a
rough idea we'll go through many of the
details as I said all of the everything
here can be found just go to google and
type in any string will you'll find this
very very quickly um so I just want to
say cut you know what can you do with
the linear did you know but linear
dynamical systems you know I'll give you
a rough idea so I'm not going to go
through the equations here obviously but
we have a mechanical system with 16
degrees of freedom actually 8 degrees of
freedom here and we have two inputs into
out but do you think of the mechanical
system some kind of motion control
system something like that you have two
inputs and yes--you outputs and what you
want to do is find an input that'll move
the output over to some desired thing
that's that's this 1-2 vector one thing
you can do is just figure out what's the
constant you should apply now you should
figure out this what's the what's the
constant you should apply and then do it
now if you do that here's what happens
if you apply these constant inputs what
will happen is and this is kind of
obvious from intuition if you take a
mechanical system and apply some forces
to it it's going to shake it's going to
have vibration modes and here it takes
Oh something like 1500 time units for
this to converge I've written seconds
down here but if you don't like that you
can consider these picoseconds or
nanoseconds depending on the application
doesn't doesn't really matter um and you
think well wow you the thing has all
sorts of vibration modes how could you
do any better than that
and the answer is you can so it's
totally different at time axis here this
is a 59 units as opposed to 1500 this is
the input you should apply it one of the
what of one of the forces and this is
the input it's the second one and what
happens is this here's the output goes
like this and then converges exactly in
fifty time units now what I want to say
about this is no one could look at these
input signals here and say the following
oh yeah I was just about to try that
there's these are not obvious you have
to know what you're doing
to come up with signals like this now
this is a kind of thing you can do if
you want to know what the timing can do
after you take 263 that you couldn't do
before this is one of them
I should add you know there's a lot of
practical applications of this
let me just mention one right now so
take an XY stage where you have an
extremely expensive machine let's say
certain lithography and you're printing
a bunch of things well how does that
work you shift things over a little bit
you have to wait obviously for it to
stop shaking before you can actually do
your print because of Simon pointed out
here we're now doing lithography at the
way you know way way down at the
nanometer level and things like that um
so how does this what does this do this
says if you just like shift over you
know 2 centimeters and wait for the
thing to stop shaking you wait a long
time if you know what you do and you
apply an input to the to the XY stage to
move it optimally something like this
the whole throughput under your machine
is can be a whole lot higher so I just
want to attention one application of
this another obvious one is that this
drive head positioning where a disk
drive head will get a at a request to
speak track 230 and if you can do it in
4 and 1/2 milliseconds that's without
and arrive there without vibration
that's great if it takes you 17 that is
not great so these are the types of
things ok I think I'm going to go over
to 360 for now and say a little bit
about this class so this class is
basically about optimization and so I'm
going to say a few things about
optimization just you know what it what
is it and all that sort of stuff I won't
say much again all of this and much more
is available on the web so you can get a
very good idea of what you're you're
what what the topic is okay so in
mathematical optimization
vitamist guess a mathematical here
because in a broad audience it can be
many other things for example G type
optimization into Google usually means
something like quick website
optimization or something like that so
okay um so the idea is that you form a
mathematical model of the problem you
have and it could be anything
well I'll talk about what it might be in
a minute you have some variables that's
the x's these are the things that you
want to choose and you minimize some
objective function that's how you decide
how good the design is and you have some
constraints and the constraint says that
you won't consider any
designs that violate these constraints
so this means you have to come in within
budget within time something can mean
many things and optimal is just as the
one that meets the constraints and has
the lowest possible objective so what
would be some examples well here are
some here's some ones that people you
know that you might know about want to
be portfolio optimization and here your
variables are the amounts invested in
different assets so how much you can
invest in different assets or asset
classes and you have to choose well the
constraint was one did you have a budget
you have a total amount that you're
going to invest but you might have
things like a maximum or minimum
investment for asset you could have a
minimum return and of course you could
have things like margin margin limits
and things like that now the objective
here might be that given all the
constraints and a minimum return a
required minimum return to minimize the
overall risk or return variance so this
would be a typical objective in in
finance um a second one quite different
would be just devising an electronic
circuit so here you have a circuit
you've chosen the circuit topology and
you want to choose the width and length
of all the devices and of course you
have manufacturing limits you can't make
it smaller than your fav is going to
allow and it's got to be fast enough so
you've got timing requirements it's
going to have to whatever you're making
is going to have to clock at 1.5
gigahertz or whatever it is and you have
an area constraint the area you might be
given an area constraint that will
affect multi economics of the whole
thing and the objective might be meeting
meet all the constraints and optimize
the power consumption why because that's
going to give you your best battery life
please just rough ideas and a final area
would be data fitting so let me say a
little bit about about that that's a
very different thing and in in the first
two applications you are choosing it's
things that where there's action
involved like a portfolio optimization
is how should I invest device sizing is
how shall I build the circuit in data
fitting it's kind of the opposite yeah
you're actually using it to you're
looking at that data and here what
you're doing is you're
a model so you did variables might be
some model parameters there might be a
few and there may be a very large number
and you have prior information and
limits on that and the objective would
be some measure of the misfit or
prediction error so that's so this is
what the optimization is very widely
used in in data fitting even to the
point where some people would claim that
almost that all up data fitting and much
of statistics comes down to optimization
I mean actual people in statistics would
say that there that's an overstatement
but anyway all right um let's talk about
solving optimization problems it's you
can form an optimization problem and
people do all the time in fact that's
actually very useful because it just
it's a clearer way to think about what
yet what do you want you actually write
down the specs of what you know what are
you doing what are the things you want
you have to choose what are the
constraints what is it you really try
how would you judge if it's good or not
so it's a good exercise just to form a
problem but the real interest of course
is in solving them now here's the bad
news
it turns out most problems you can't
solve so sorry about that
now then you can solve them in some
compromised way you can either have an
extremely long computation time and be
guaranteed to find the right solution or
you can have a fast way that's not
guaranteed to find the solution this
sort of thing um now and this is what
this course is about there are some very
important exceptions and these are
mathematical optimization problems you
can solve extremely well so I mean you
can get to solve efficiently and
reliably and some you probably have
heard of what is least squares they're
ordinary least squares and I've got lots
of other names in statistics they would
call this regression and it's got fancy
extensions like linear control signal
processing filtering a lot of things are
really basically fancy forms of least
squares is a lot of Equalization and
communications are just least squares
problems um at these times you can solve
them exactly there's no there's no
compromise you get it exactly always
works you get the right thing
now another area that people in EE know
less about but historically
has been used in he is linear
programming that that's that's another
area where where there is no compromise
and the parents in fact sort of the the
parent of all of these problems is
convex optimization so uh and I'll say a
little bit I think I'll jump through
some of these things about the details
of least squares but least squares is uh
is there anything you solve a very
specific problem you just minimize the
sum of squares
that's all connected that's that's
widely used for many applications and so
on
a linear programming that's a different
thing and this is something a lot of
people in a II haven't seen although I
think it's going to make much more it's
going to be making an impact and it is
in several areas in fact as I already
mentioned one application was compressed
sensing that we just saw I mean that's
not quite linear programming but it's
very very close so linear program you
minimize a linear function subject to
some linear inequality constraints now
of course the details here don't matter
at all but this is this is an
interesting set of problems because for
these problems there are no analytical
solutions so you're not going to hear
about this and you're in your your math
class generally that's changing I hope
it changes much more but you're not
going to hear about this because this
there's no analytical solution is just
we can simply solve them it's that
simple
sunday supplement is sort of the parent
of these and these are these are often
mathematical optimization problems with
special forms and they include least
squares and linear programs as special
cases and I'm not going to go into the
details of what this means that's not
right here what I really want to do is
just give you a rough idea of what what
the course is about what do you do with
it and so on so for these problems
there's no analytical solution but
what's been developed in the last
fifteen maybe ten years that depends on
how you set your threshold on quality
and efficiency are very good methods to
solve these things so these are these
are now they're still challenges and in
solving convex optimization problems but
for many in many cases there's just a
technology and so my opinion on this is
that this is just
this should be in your toolbox its
effect it's a big tool fact I didn't put
it at the top of the toolbox not in the
bottom part because it can be used for
lots and lots of things
okay now the let me tape up what the
challenge is but I turn it around I
think it's a positive thing um it's
actually not that easy to say of a
problem is convex you don't know there's
a lot of tricks and so on and it's not
it's not as it's not easy it's not like
recognizing a least squares problem or
something like that so you really have
to be trained to do this and people are
finding these all the time if you want
to take the full 10-week course you can
get a rough idea of that um my own
opinion is that's probably more than you
need to know if you just want to use
these things and the hope is that the
the abbreviated courses will be
something closer to what would you need
to know to use these things you're not
going to know every detail and so on but
what would you need to know to use these
things okay
now the you know the goal the primary
goal of this course is to basically for
its Mon modeling it's on formulating
problems this way we do a lot of
applications in the in in the course and
I should warn you if you go to google
and type in this phrase you will go to
what you'll see other courses and lots
of other universities um some are based
on this course others are much more
theoretical so don't don't be put off by
those that's that's the traditional one
and that's something like that DSP
course from MIT in 1965 which was super
theoretical so this is just part of the
shift towards a more applications based
course and I'll finish it by just saying
a little brief history about this so the
the mathematics of it is a hundred years
old basically and was pretty well
developed by 1970 there's a big Stanford
connection because in fact one of the
most widely used contact optimization
problem is linear
programming and the principal algorithm
for that was developed by George Dantzig
who was at Stanford for many decades -
excellent - State now there was a lot of
interest in the 60s and in the 70s there
were actually two times where advances
in these in these areas landed on the
front page of the New York Times so but
I think in my opinion what is most
interesting and most I think and the
reason why I think people should know
about this is there's just tons of new
applications and these are in areas like
control signal processing communications
circuit design machine learning areas
like like this so I think that's a very
exciting time and this is this is part
of it's a tool that's being used and a
lot of application areas and these
courses would be a very good way to get
a rough idea to get a not a rough idea a
working basic working knowledge in this
area so I think I'll quit there and
maybe there'll be some questions or
something I'd be more than happy to
answer them professor Boyd thank you
very much we'll take questions as we
closed what I'd like to do now is just
turn on shift gears a little bit we want
to thank again professor Board and
professor Wong for participating in this
program which gave you a reasonably good
idea of where in jaffe electrical
engineering to use the future hopefully
some of you see that as well as as well
we hope to try to give you a sense of
some of the courses that will be the
building blocks to create that future
you've heard about two of those courses
but what I could do now is shift gears
and talk a little bit about how you can
engage in some of the courses if you
heard about today and give you some
background on the Stanford center for
professional development our Center
serves as the bridge between industry
and Stanford University and we offer
graduate and professional education
courses and programs to meet the career
long education needs of technology
professionals engineers scientists
managers and exec
is that skip you teased in part of the
Silicon Valley actually for over forty
years now and we believe based on
customer feedback and discussions with
companies the Stanford education
provides new and innovative ways for
companies and the people in those
companies to create innovation which
leads to a more competitive Silicon
Valley scpd's portfolio is outlined here
on this slide we offer graduate programs
the first which identified here is the
non degree option where students can
take individual courses on a quarter by
quarter basis for Stanford University
credit many of the students who
participate in this category actually
can accumulate up to eighteen units get
a very good sense of how courses and
offerings are in a specific department
often they can in the domain specific
domain can be applied to a master's
degree so for instance if you take a
number of EE courses this summer and on
a non degree option basis all you need
to do is provide us with transcript
which proves that you can do the
Stanford level work and you will be
admitted to that course and you can
continue to accumulate those credits
toward a master's degree we also offer
graduate certificate programs a number
of the courses in this sequence if you
have seen here today can accumulate
toward a graduate certificate those are
typically a specific area of study
usually three to five graduate courses
in electrical engineering for example
there are four courses and that's one
very solid way to participate if you
already have a terminal master's degree
in this specific domain finally we have
a master's degree called the honors
cooperative program this has been in
existence since 1969 we have a number of
degree areas electrical engineering is
one of those and you must apply to the
department and get accepted as part of
the cohort you then have the full rights
and privileges
and you have the opportunity to have
continued to you to work as a
professional while taking this degree on
a part-time basis finally we have an
audit program these are courses where
students can observe the class not
participate with homeworks and
assignments in in an interactive way and
no credit is earned but this may give
you a sense of a particular course or
domain SBPD conducts 95% of its business
at a distance we offer live lectures
online and those lectures are available
during the active quarter 24/7 and we
allow you to keep pace with the lectures
at your convenience and in in around
your work and family schedule the
courses typically have homework
assignments with them we ask that you
submit those almost through the SBPD so
we can help monitor them as well as
follow along with the faculty
requirements they may have you make a
double submission but this is a great
way to make sure that you're secure we
do have a requirement in the event that
the course has a test we ask that you
identify an exam monitor not your best
friend or your wife but instead your
boss or someone in HR this will allow
you to observe the rules and
requirements that Stanford University
has for for conducting that test here
are the ways to walk you a little bit of
how you can enroll this summer quarter
is open now for enrollment and will
remain open until June 17 if you're
interested in rolling an electrical
engineering course at this summer
or any other graduate courses we offer
forty this summer you must enroll online
through scpd's website and spdif
stanford.edu
we do require an official field academic
transcript however we do accept copies
as that official transcript is being
routed to us tuition is identified in a
number of categories the higher rates of
our the non degree option students as if
you don't participate as a through a
member company our website identifies
more company on a per-unit basis there's
a significant cost savings and typically
courses are two to four units as you saw
we have a new pilot program an
experiment this summer with the two unit
courses in electrical engineering the
audit tuition on a per course basis for
non-member companies is a 1150 and if
you're a member cause of course if
you're a member company the audit
tuition is nine hundred ninety five
dollars the enrollment deadlines and
assistance located on a city's website
I'm gonna walk you through a little bit
of scpd's new website we have something
called my Stanford connection many of
you who participated in this webinar
actually enrolled through this we thank
you very much this is the way that you
can access courses and information about
a CPD we'll have the latest
announcements as well you'll engage and
you'll see your course videos through
this link here's an example if you were
to do a search on a specific course you
would identify that domain or the
specific course if you know the name and
then you would go to this page in the
course section and you would hit the
button enroll in this section which is
highlighted that would leave you to
completion and you would hit this cart
which is in the upper right hand of the
screen when you're in my Stanford
connection that you click on that cart
as much as you would do at amazon.com or
a similar application and that will
position you to a registration page to
make sure that you're your basket is
correct and then you would be asked for
to provide payment at that time well
what what I'd like to do now is take a
quick poll again I mentioned here a
couple of different ways to engage we
are still welcoming questions into the
queue but here what I'd like to know in
this poll is are you interested in
enrolling in summer courses in
electrical engineering there are a
couple of choices I'm ready to enroll
this quarter summer quarter is not right
for me but I'm interested in EE courses
later in the year in September one the
traditional academic year starts I'm not
interested but
no colleagues going to be interested or
finally I'm not interested at this done
so if you could make your selection I
would appreciate it
a few boats are still coming in all
righty I'm going to close the polls now
and it seems that some people are
actually ready to enroll a few of you
are interested but summer is not the
right time somebody knows a colleague
who may be interested we'd love to
follow up with you and some of you may
have are just viewing this and not ready
at this time so we hope that maybe you
come back to us at a later time when you
are ready as I mentioned SCPD not only
offers graduate courses and professional
education on a year-round basis most of
the offerings are online but we also
offer free webinars are going offering
these webinars is to create a learning
community we have some free stuff or
webinars seminars as well we have
graduate and professional education
courses which we believe will help you
on your journey the next webinar we will
offers on June 24 this will be from 9:00
to 10:00 a.m.
or we will be joined by Maggie Johnson
who's the director of educational
affairs the undergraduate studies for
the computer science department and also
has a role as a Learning and Development
Manager at Google she has done a lot of
work in IT management and she'll be
talking about contemporary IT
benchmarking in analytic forensics
perhaps she's using some of the tools
that best employ talked about we look
forward to having you join us on that
webinar and with that we are nearing the
conclusion of our webinar here today I'm
going to encourage you to follow up with
SCPD keep in touch we have a number of
courses some of which you heard about
here today and I've listed them on this
slide if you're interested in following
up with those on registrants of these
courses you can simply click on the link
here enrolled on stanford.edu you can
also encourage your company become a
member so that you and your colleagues
continue on the journey
for a lifelong education something that
Stanford views is vitally important to
the vibrance and competitiveness of the
Silicon Valley and Beyond with this we'd
like to thank you here today
we still have some questions in the
queue we'll be continuing to answer
those offline we wish you the very best
and this concludes our webinar and we
thank you and have a very good day